this past weekend Joe Biden debuted his
new campaign slogan you know what it is
have you heard it true story this is
real the slogan is no malarkey no
malarkey yes
no malarkey a 77 year old presidential
candidate is going with a phrase from
the 1920s now I could not believe it so
I thought we'd talk to Joe Biden's
director of marketing and social media
eugene fielding who is joining us from
washington d.c hello Eugene hello I hear
you but I don't know where you are
Jr you're not facing the camera Eugene
oh that way you go hi Jimmy no no not
one of the Jimmy no my name is Conan
it's Conan's I'm Eugene yeah Eugene let
me ask okay aren't you a little worried
that no malarkey reinforces the idea
that mr. Biden is old and well let's
face it out of touch
no it's genuine no fully and look we're
active with all the young people where
they are I mean we're always on Twitter
with number sign no malarkey
hey you okay you know you mean hashtag
oh do i what
but listen conan we have really neato
promo tie-ins like getting your own no
malarkey ranger badge and boxes a
crackerjack okay yeah listen this crowd
may be applauding for some reason but
Cracker Jacks are not popular anymore
how about this the next 20,000 people to
register their electronic mail at Joe
Biden dot geo cities dot-com will get a
free no stinkin malarkey odor eater in
Seoul right yeah I don't I think that I
don't think that's kind of lame oh well
what if I told you that on all of Joe's
campaign stops he'll be bringing out the
guy who whistled The Andy Griffith theme
song yes why okay plus this week we're
launching a new snapchat filter where
you can become your own favorite Beetle
Bailey character look at this Conan I'm
general half-track ya know what no one
has what no one has read that cartoon in
like 30 years it's not no voters look
what are the kids love these days the
video games right you know what that is
true yeah so that's why we are happy to
announce that digital banners are being
placed in the Nintendo football game
Tecmo Bowl what that is my cellular
phone hello oh you want my social
security number no no you're not do not
do that Yugi eight seven three
Eugene feeling everyone a real person